the fda has officially voted unanimously
to approve the fouchy algae for kids
between the ages of 5 and 11. a couple
of days ago on this show we heard from
yale epidemiologist harvey rich who said
that he recommended homeschooling any
healthy children who were mandated to
get the vaccine pulled them out of
school he just felt it was not worth any
potential risk given that healthy
children face very very little risk of
serious illness or death from covid well
the fda inadvertently seems to have
proven professor rish's point when one
of the fda panel members who voted to
inject the kids gave this rationale for
it
we're never going to learn about how
vaccine is unless we start giving it
yeah that's just the way it goes
that's the only way
you
did dr fauci run out of beagles or
something the only way to test the
safety of a vaccine is to inject it into
a bunch of kids
this is like that time nancy pelosi said
the only way to find out what was in the
obamacare bill was to pass the obamacare
bill except in the case of obamacare the
worst case scenario just involves a lot
of wasted spending and constitutional
fighting and things like that in this
case
it involves injecting your kids
with an experimental drug that they
almost certainly don't need
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from shady ganley
formerly jaquarius okay that's fine who
says
even hunter's artwork requires him to
blow through a pipe
that's true see these are
constant themes there are these motifs
moving through all of hunter biden's
work whether it is on the canvas or
whether it is on skid row
if you want to be able to make it around
your community
your country especially with all this
crazy bite inflation going on
you got to check out get upside i am
thrilled to introduce a very very timely
app that you were going to want to get
this very second get upside
what is get upside get upside allows you
to make up to 25 cents for every gallon
of gas
every time you fill up you download the
free get upside app in the app store or
google play right now you use promo code
knowles canon wles you get a bonus 25
cents per gallon on your first fill up
that means up to 50 cents cash back per
gallon do not pay full price at the pump
anymore get cash back using get upside
down load the app for free and use promo
code knowles k w l e s to get up to 50
cents per gallon cash back on your first
tank some people who drive a lot
are making as much as two to three
hundred dollars a month in cash
there is no catch the cash gets right
added to your bank account it can be put
through paypal it can be put through an
e-gift card for amazon or other brands
super simple don't leave money on the
table download the free get upside app
use promo code nolskwles to get up to 50
cents per gallon cashback on your first
tank that is code knowles
they want to
test their drug on your kids
that remember the other day we were all
up in arms that dr fauci performed
experiments on beagles
oh the poor little well right now they
want to do that on your kids and the fda
panel member is saying that himself
because well the only way we're going to
know if it's safe is if we inject all
your kids with this stuff and then we
just see what happens
what could go wrong
it's not my kids it's your kids well i
don't you know if it were my kids maybe
i'd be a little more worried but it's
your kids so whatever
that's what they're doing to your kids
bodies now what are they doing to your
kids minds it's even worse
okay speaking of what your kids are
being taught there's a professor at
rutgers right now
she just went on a
show the root
and
this rutgers professor was pontificating
about white people about race and
society and uh to cut to the chase
she unlike white people very much
i think that white people are committed
to being villains in the aggregate right
the real sort of issue here you know
i've heard people sort of say it is
one i think that white people viscerally
fear it's not that white people don't
know right what they have done they know
they fear that there is no other way to
be human but the way in which they are
human which is to so you know like you
talk to white people and whenever you
really want to have a reckoning about it
they say stuff like you know it's just
human nature if y'all had all of this
power you would have done the same thing
right
and it's like no that's what white
humans did white human beings thought
there's a world here and we own it prior
to them black and brown people have been
sailing across oceans interacting with
each other for centuries without total
subjugation domination and colonialism i
do think that all of us can sort of
agree that our politics that says like
there are superior and inferior human
beings just isn't the way to go and
that's the thing that white people don't
trust us to do because they are so
corrupt you know their thinking is so
morally and spiritually bankrupt about
power
it's wrong to say that some people are
better than other people you know you
know that's wrong
and you know who does that those
corrupt evil villainous smelly dirty
rotten awful white people they all those
horrible disgusting filthy cockroach
white people they say that some people
are better than others you know man i
hate those white people that was awful
so from the historical perspective what
this lunatic is saying is just not true
she's saying that before european
colonization and exploration
black people
untouched by the evil white man had been
sailing across oceans and living in sort
of some sort of edenic paradise none of
that is true i don't i look i know they
said christopher columbus discovered
america some people say it was leif
eriksen but
i i don't i don't think anyone is
claiming that someone from sub-saharan
africa who had never met the evil awful
white man actually discovered america or
something like that right so that is
that is not the case and in that if they
had they would not have engaged in
colonialism or imperialism or anything
everyone would have lived in kumbaya
that's not even true in africa right i
mean what is at the heart of this crazy
racial politics is the slave trade
and colonialism and imperialism as she's
alluding to
where did that slave trade come from did
it come because the white man showed up
in africa and then just threw a big net
on people and just took them away no
there was a pre-existing slave trade in
africa
among africans
a lot of it was controlled actually by
north africans but there was a huge
slave trade in sub-saharan africa
there still is slavery in africa to this
very day
so historically that doesn't make any
sense but
what whatever who cares i mean this
lunatic professor who probably shouldn't
have graduated high school is now
teaching students i'm sure she has
advanced degrees and she's pushing the
same kind of ridiculous racial nonsense
that that goes back to this professor
leonard jeffries
you you sometimes hear this from people
like nick cannon or other black
nationalist types that the white people
are villains they're just evil they're
just so corrupt they're spiritually
bankrupt
and the black people are good and the
white people are the ice people and the
black people are the sun people i mean
this this kind of craziness has actually
been taught for a number of decades but
my point is actually even outside of the
academy
my point is this
on a political level we are told
that
white people are the absolute top of the
privilege hierarchy they are the
oppressors they can do no wrong they get
all the special privileges
we are told that men are the very tippy
top we are told that straight people are
the very tippy top
we're told that cisgender people people
who know what sex they are they're at
the very tippy top
and yet
could you say these sorts of things in
public about any other race
of course not you could not go out and
make a bunch of disparaging comments
about black people and call them
villains and call them
murderers and call them evil and
spiritually bankrupt and corrupt you
couldn't do that you would be
ostracized you'd be certainly fired from
your teaching job you'd be ostracized
you might be charged with some kind of
hate crime you couldn't do it about
asian people you couldn't do it about
hispanic people
you could only do it about white people
because what we are told
is that white people are the most
powerful dominant group in the whole
world who can get away with anything but
in fact they're the only race of people
that you're publicly allowed to and
actually encouraged to criticize
and taught that should be abolished
right we need to abolish whiteness we
need to eradicate whiteness
obviously you couldn't say that about
any other race same is true on sex
you're not allowed to criticize women
you are almost obligated to criticize
men
same is true on sexual desire you're not
allowed to criticize homosexuals or
polyamorous people or transgender people
or any you're not allowed to raise any
question about these things that could
get you
criticized banned ostracized
charged for the hate crime but you can
do that to straight people the
the reality
of
hierarchy
in the country
is radically different from what we are
told the hierarchy is according to the
intersectional left critical race theory
the gender ideology it's actually
the opposite
speaking of young people
being unfairly characterized do you
remember kyle rittenhouse
cal rittenhouse was this young man who
during the blm riots went out and tried
to put it you know put out some fires as
there were arsonists running rough shot
and people destroying property and
threatening people and killing people
and when some of the antifa lunatics
came after him he shot them in
self-defense
it would seem i mean we have videos of
these things it looks like he shot them
in self-defense
so
they're trying to prosecute him
he's a young evil white guy conservative
i mean he checks every box for
throw this guy in jail and throw away
the key
the prosecution is is really going after
him
and
as the trial begins the judge
actually is mocking the prosecution for
their ridiculous ideology
if there were any evidence in this case
and i would i would love to hear because
i haven't seen it if there was any
evidence in this case that mr rosenbaum
physically attacked anyone else that
night chased anyone else that night
assaulted anyone else that night
threatened anybody with a weapon that
night
we can talk about that but i don't hear
any evidence to that effect all we're
talking about is arson we're talking
about being loud and disorderly we're
talking about you know being i can't
believe some of the things you're seeing
and what you're writing talking about is
arson come on
i love that judge at the end all you're
talking about is arson come on i mean
this guy this prosecutor here is he is
the guy from msnbc they're not literally
the same guy but it's the exact same
point you remember the guy from msnbc
he's standing in front of a burning
building he's saying these are fiery but
mostly peaceful protests i would say
other than the arson and the looting and
the mugging and the beating and the
murdering it's mostly uh peaceful so if
you can show me
judge
that these guys you know we're doing
anything other than uh burn and pillage
and kill and steal and if you anything
else
okay then um then we then we can have
that conversation
in the kyle rittenhouse trial as the
prosecutors are talking to the judge and
trying to get this kid thrown in prison
forever
for
what would seem to be defending himself
the
the
prosecution is attempting to frame the
debate and we know that whoever frames
the issue wins the debate so
what the prosecution is trying to do is
say that the people that kyle
rittenhouse shot
were victims now of course rittenhouse's
point is no no they were coming after me
they were chasing me these are very
violent people they were burning stuff
down and i shot them in self-defense and
what the prosecution wants to do is call
them
victims the judge having none of it
this is bad character evidence your
honor this is an attempt to tell the
jury mr rosenbaum's a bad guy and
deserve to die that's really what it is
he was an arsonist he was a rioter he
was starting fights or he's not starting
fights he was starting problems he was
disorderly he was loud he was uh
whatever
this is really bad stuff your honor okay
you're what you're doing is you're
prejudicing the jury against
the person that i'm representing just
because he was a filthy degenerate
criminal who was burning stuff down and
committing crimes in the moment and was
chasing this kid who then shot him in
self-defense
okay
judge that's that's so wrong
now of course
what the prosecution is trying to do
is and actually the judge just shut this
down is bring up
a bunch of other problems that kyle
rittenhouse had had that were not
related to this to this moment but
in this prevailing
ideology
the if you are
a
white certainly just heard it from that
professor a white
conservative oh my gosh that's awful
that's probably worst of all if you're
because you can be black and a
conservative and if you're a black
conservative you're a white supremacist
they do that to candace all the time or
larry elder or anybody
so if you're a white conservative male
straight
you know you are presumed guilty until
proven innocent and even if you shoot
someone in self-defense that is not
permitted and the force of the state
will come after you for that now
speaking of criminal justice
there was a really
there's so rarely good news
these days but there was some really
wonderful fireworks yesterday on capitol
hill
merrick garland the supposedly moderate
attorney general for joe biden showed up
to capitol hill to be grilled by the
senate merrick garland had to answer
because he sent out a memorandum
describing parents who went to their
school boards and questioned radical
racial theories like the ones that we
heard from rutgers or radical sexual
theories like transgenderism questioned
that being taught in schools the parents
said we don't really like that we don't
like being told that
you know boys can become girls we don't
like our kids being taught that white
people are evil that america is evil we
don't like that
merrick garland described them as
domestic terrorists so he was dragged
before capitol hill
senator tom cotton
ripped him a new one
one of the news reports signed in that
letter which you presumably mean
is from loudoun county virginia no
that's not that is not um what i was
talking about well you keep citing news
reports and that's the most prominent
news report that anyone in america has
seen that refers to scott smith whose 15
year old daughter was raped
she was raped
in a bathroom by a boy wearing girl's
clothes and the loudoun county school
board covered it up because it would
have interfered with their transgendered
policy during pride month
and that man scott smith because he went
to a school board and tried to defend
his daughter's rights was condemned
internationally do you apologize to
scott smith and his 15 year old daughter
judge
senator anyone whose
child was raped as a most horrific crime
i can imagine and is certainly entitled
and protected by the first amendment to
protest to their school board about that
but he was cited by the school board
association that's fine as a domestic
terrorist which we now know that letter
and those reports were the basis for
your
this is this is that's wrong judges is
shameful
it is shameful it is shameful it is
disgraceful
cotton did great here cotton
merrick garland kept trying to evade the
issue and he does a very good job
garland of pretending to be the look i'm
just the reasonable quiet nice moderate
guy he's not moderate at all he's
describing his parents as domestic
terrorists
and tom cotton was absolutely right to
call him out what i'm more interested in
here though
than just what a garland is and how much
tom cotton totally owned him is the
media aspect okay to me the big story
here
is the story
the daily wire broke this story
about the rape in virginia
that the school covered up because it
didn't want to
have to answer for its transgender
bathroom policies okay the daily wire
broke that story wasn't the new york
times wasn't the washington post wasn't
nbc news wasn't any of the
very well-funded investigative news
outlets it was us little ole us here
at a website that was just a tiny little
blog five years ago
now that story is dominating the
national conversation it dominated
capitol hill yesterday it might cost
terry mcauliffe the virginia
governorship
that entire race right now the virginia
governor race between mcauliffe and
yonkin
is coming down to
education
whether parents have the right to to
have some say in the way their kids are
taught
and specifically coming down to this
story
and i'm not saying it just to toot our
own horn here at the daily wire i'm
saying to make a point conservatives
very rarely do investigative journalism
it loses money it's a very expensive
endeavor we don't have the
infrastructure anywhere close to what
the left has to do investigative
journalism
but just this one story
has totally transformed the way we're
talking about this issue it might it
might transform who's the governor of
virginia
there's a lesson to be learned here we
need to do a lot more of this this was
just one story how many more stories are
there like this
if we do a little investigative work and
we start to set the conversation we
don't just react we don't just criticize
we start to set the conversation we
start to pick what stories we're going
to focus on we start to uncover things
that the left is trying to cover up
how much more powerful would that be
how many more races could we win how
many more issues could we win on
really good stuff from cotton although
the prize of the day i think i have to
give to my friend
ted cruz garland had a real
rhetorical beating up there on capitol
hill
ted cruz was the one
who would not let him evade the point
you saw with with tom cotton
he keeps trying to pin him down and then
garland keeps evading then finally
cotton goes alright whatever this is
disgraceful you're a disgrace judge you
should resign
fair enough
cruz asks garland a very specific
question
garland has a conflict of interest it
seems because his son-in-law has a
business interest in a critical race
theory company
so then garland goes out and he starts
pushing critical race theory in the
schools obviously that's a conflict of
interest
ted cruz had a simple question hey judge
did you
look into the ethics of this and try to
get approval from an ethics body on your
decision to send to this memorandum and
he will not let the issue go
did you seek an ethics opinion judge you
know how to ask questions and answer
them did you seek an ethics opinion you
asked me whether i sought an ethics
opinion about something that would have
a predictable effect on something this
has no predictable effect in the way
that you're talking about it so if
critical race theory is taught in more
schools does your son-in-law make more
money memo has nothing if critical race
theory is taught in more schools does
your son-in-law make more money yes or
no this memorandum has nothing to do
with critical race will you answer if
you thought it was the kind of
curriculum will you answer if you saw it
i am answering the best i can yes or no
did you seek an ethics opinion this
memorandum has did you seek an ethics
opinion this memorandum has nothing to
do with general are you refusing to
answer if you sought an ethics i'm
telling you that there's no possible so
you're saying no just answer it directly
you know how to answer a question
directly did you seek an ethics opinion
i'm telling you that if i thought there
was any reason to believe there was a
conflict of interest i would do that but
i cannot why do you refuse to answer the
question why won't you just say no
i'm sorry
you're not going to answer the question
i'm sorry ask the question again did you
seek an ethics opinion i'm saying again
i would seek an ethics opinion so no is
the answer correct
senator your time is up
is this garland guide stupid is he just
a little thick
that he doesn't know what question ted
cruz has been pestering him with for
several minutes at that point
gosh he must be the dumbest guy in the
world well maybe not maybe he's not i
actually don't think he's a dumb guy i
think he's got really stellar
credentials i think he went to really
fancy schools i think he's been a
federal judge and i think he's playing
dumb
ted cruz is asking did you seek an
ethics opinion before you sent out this
memo that was going to benefit your
son-in-law
merrick garland answers it's not going
to benefit my son-in-law ted cruz says
that's not the question i asked you i
said did you seek an ethic it's a very
simple question
it's like did you eat eggs for breakfast
this morning did you did you seek an
ethics opinion i'm not saying what
should the conclusion of the ethics
opinion be i'm not saying did you need
to get an ethics i'm just asking did you
do it
i i no
senator i'm answering you i just didn't
know a senator i'm and then he says can
you answer the simple question he goes
well i'm sorry what was the question
you've been asked the question 100 times
did you seek an ethics opinion but
merrick garland is a very shrewd
politician
and garland knows that if he gives that
answer it's going to look really really
crooked
which
it
is if you have not heard already the
daily wire
has signed allison williams to lead a
very special sports series exclusively
for our members i was really hoping that
i would lead the sports series you know
i was going to talk about the home runs
you know and the slam dunks and stuff
but that's okay we got allison
she was
an espn season sports reporter
she announced her resignation last week
because disney which is espn's parent
company is forcing their employees to
get the fouchy algae or get fired here
at the daily wire
leftist elites do not dictate our
content you do so if you want sports
content without the woke become a member
at dailywire.com
subscribe use code do not comply it
check out for 25 off
what's that url dailywire.com subscribe
use code do not comply for 25 off and
join the fight also check out
morningwire great show get it on apple
spotify wherever you get your podcast
leave a five star review if you like it
we'll be right back with a lot more
twix
wants to trans your kids
twix you know the delicious crunchy
candy probably gonna get a lot of that
at halloween twix
they want to trans your kids uh there
was an ad came out for twix
in the ad a little boy dresses like a
little girl but he's not dressing like a
little girl for halloween he's dressing
like a little girl because i guess he
thinks he's a little girl and he has
abusive parents
so
in the ad he gets a new babysitter a new
nanny and the babysitter in the nanny is
a witch
you buckled i'm still wearing my
princess dress do you want to wear it
[Music]
hey you
princess
you look like a girl why are you wearing
that dressing like this makes me feel
good is that your nanny she looks weird
you look weird your nanny looks weird
you guys are both weird no we're just
different boys don't wear dresses
whoa
whoa
where is it coming from
what's happening
we should go
[Music]
will you come back yeah
probably come on
so
this ad from twix
i don't know i i saw this from libs of
tiktok one of the greatest accounts on
twitter
i don't i guess twix made it if not some
but it looks like it's a twix ad it
looks like i don't really watch tv a lot
but looks looks legit to me in the ad
a witch
seriously injures or possibly kills
a child
for telling another child that
boys should not dress up like girls all
the time
and so the witch
attacks him this is a perceptive ad this
is a really perceptive ad
because witchcraft is on the rise okay
i'm not i don't want to sound people are
going to say i've got a tin foil hat on
or something that i sound like a crazy
person i'm
i'm quoting the atlantic okay the
atlantic magazine just last year comes
out with an article why witchcraft is on
the rise and you see this by the way you
can read about this in in journals you
see a lot of it on social media there is
a rise in witchcraft in the wicca sort
of witchy religion people will describe
themselves as witches and there's all
sorts of kooky new age spirituality here
and
all this creepy sex stuff
has a relation to it it has a
relationship to the occult i mean the
very idea of transgenderism has a
relationship to these strange gnostic
religions which say that your body has
nothing to do with who you really are
and that actually there's the secret
secret knowledge esoteric knowledge that
really you can only access if if you
deal in these kind of weird ideologies
it reminds me of of one of the greatest
lines ever uttered in politics
this is a line we have returned to on
this show a number of times
it was from pat robertson who is now
he's the very aged host at the 700 club
he ran for president before he was a
very prominent evangelical leader and in
1992
pat robertson said quote
the feminist agenda is not about equal
rights for women it is about a socialist
anti-family political movement that
encourages women to leave their husbands
kill their children practice witchcraft
destroy capitalism and become lesbians
and it's very easy
to say that this is a crazy insane
lunatic line right
but it's harder to point out the flaw in
his reasoning i can't which where's the
flaw
feminism and socialism overlap a lot
that's true
think of the most radical feminists you
know often they
are more open to things like socialism
it's anti-family well that's certainly
true right a woman needs a man like a
fish needs a bicycle i was gloria
steinem
encourages women to leave their husbands
same point kill their children is is
feminism pro-abortion yeah
destroy capitalism well yeah we just
talked about that with the socialism
thing become lesbians yeah there's you
know i'm not saying all feminists are
lesbians but there's definitely some
overlap okay and then the the one that
people always thought was the most over
the top was practice witchcraft but this
is
rising you'll read about covens and
things like that in brooklyn
you'll hear people describe themselves
as witchy women and that sort of stuff
and what they will tell you is oh
michael don't take this seriously this
isn't like a real religious thing it's
more of a kind of political statement
it's kind of like atheists just saying
you know this is my it's it's hearkening
back to old mythology and old pagan
ideas right i know that's right of
course it is
that it happens to be the case that
there's more between heaven and earth
and is dreamt of in our philosophies but
moreover even if you're doing this thing
ironically like there there is there was
a satanist movement in the 20th century
that was kind of ironic they didn't
really believe in the existence of god
or satan they just believed that you
should
do all the things that satanists do
you know you should pursue your own
selfish interests you shouldn't care
about others you should pursue your own
based appetites so it's kind of ironic
satanism it's kind of ironic witchcraft
sometimes and the thing is if you do
something ironically for your whole life
it's just sincere it's earnest you're
actually just doing it
and this is
true all of the everybody's got to serve
somebody all right the great political
philosopher bob dylan understood that
everybody's got to serve somebody so you
might be thinking
oh
i don't believe in all that kooky
nonsense
i'm i don't believe in religion i'm just
pragmatic i'm just realistic i'm just
whatever
but you do you
as they say politics is downstream of
culture culture is downstream of
religion cult and culture comes from the
same root word okay what
what you do the way you live your life
because we're incarnate beings and we
and we also have ideas and we are
motivated by ideas and we do things in
the real world it is going to have some
religious significance and in this case
it's a bunch of witches bad idea it's
not good stuff don't hang out with the
witches
pat robertson called it in the 90s we
should have listened
speaking of creepy weird gender ideology
the state department is buying into this
the state department now
is announcing for the first time
it will allow a third gender option for
u.s citizens on their passports they
have now issued one
it is the first of its kind and on your
passport you can either identify
yourself as a male
m
a female f
or something else
x
this has been building for a long time
in a way it's the logical consequence of
the homosexual rights movement from the
90s and 2000s
and really that's a consequence of the
feminist movement
all of which hold as their fundamental
premise that men and women are basically
the same that men and women are
basically
interchangeable
they're not complementary they're not
totally different they're kind of
anything a man can do a woman can do
that the
differences are only superficial so
naturally you would redefine marriage
naturally you would redefine sex itself
if m
plus w
equals m plus m
equals m plus w plus w right if they're
all the same then m equals w and they're
they're
interchangeable so the state department
has bought into this what does this mean
for you
one seems like there's a little bit of a
security risk issue here if you no
longer need to identify your sex and you
can just pretend you're some other sex
on your
passport that would seem to pose some
security problems but it's also
ridiculous from a philosophical
standpoint and it's also now part of the
governing ideology
the regime has now officially adopted
transgenderism as its governing ideology
meaning that you don't really have a
right to question it
and you've been seeing this
more and more in recent years
five years ago if you said a man as a
woman
you would be laughed at
ten years ago you'd be people would
consider committing you to an insane
asylum
now you would still be
five years ago you'd still be laughed at
today it is taken as common sense
increasingly if you say a man is not a
woman
you'll be censored on social media
you'll be asked to leave the classroom
you will be have professional
consequences at your job
you
if you do that in government you could
be accused of discrimination
pretty soon you won't really be allowed
to do it
at all
it's we talked yesterday about the
regime what's a regime a regime is that
which transcends the partisan disputes
the republican wins the democrat wins it
doesn't matter certain things remain the
same
now transgenderism is about to be part
of that
it's on the passports
it doesn't matter if a republican wins
and says this is bunk it's on
the passports
soon enough
the squishes will be defending this
okay and what you're going to hear mark
my words save this episode
i don't know if it will come true in
five years or 10 years or even sooner
than that maybe but what's going to
happen is the squishes are going to say
oh you know
look maybe
i don't agree with transgenderism okay i
don't practice transgenderism myself but
people have a right to choose if they
want to say that they're transgender
okay and that's just their right and
that's just liberty
and it's on the passports okay and
that's the government is protecting that
individual right of men to pretend that
they're women all right now i might not
agree with it but that's liberty that's
a blessing of liberty
that will you will be hearing that
probably sooner than many of us think
the ruling class
is really really
weird it's getting really bizarre really
out there okay and
at the international level
the level of these groups that transcend
nations like the united nations one of
their obsessions is climate change
because climate change used to be global
cooling then it was global warming then
it was climate change now i guess they
call it climate crisis or climate
catastrophe it is this apocalyptic
prediction
that tells us the end of the world is
imminent unless we give them all the
money and all the power
and so we've got it got to just go along
with it
they are now playing at the un
four world leaders
a
really scientific erudite serious video
of a dinosaur lecturing everybody about
extinction
listen up people
i know a thing or two about extinction
and let me tell you
and you kind of think this would be
obvious
going extinct is a bad thing
and driving yourselves extinct
in 70 million years that's the most
ridiculous thing i've ever heard
at least we had an asteroid
what's your excuse
you're headed for a climate disaster and
yet every year governments spend
hundreds of billions of public funds on
fossil fuel subsidies
imagine if we had spent hundreds of
billions per year subsidizing giant
meteors that's what you're doing right
now think of all the other things you
could do with that money
around the world people are living in
poverty
don't you think helping them would make
more sense than i don't know paying for
the demise of your entire species
let me be real for a second
you've got a huge opportunity right now
as you rebuild your economies and bounce
back from this pandemic this is
humanity's big chance
three
really important aspects here to the
dinosaur lecturing the world leaders
a sentence i never thought i would utter
first of all he goes back to this
ridicul the dinosaur does he goes back
to this ridiculous talking point that
you hear a lot from the environmentalist
lunatics and he says you're subsidizing
fossil fuels you oh my your governments
your taxpayer dollars are subsidizing
ritual uncle penny bags at the oil
company
what does that mean that obviously isn't
true so what is it what does he mean by
that
we're just giving direct payments to
the oil tycoons that's what's going on
why are we doing why would we do that
why would taxpayers and why would the
government just even from a political
optics standpoint why would they
subsidize the oil companies
because they are paying for poor people
to heat their homes among other things
what do you think oil subsidies means
we're paying the government is paying
oil companies and buying oil one because
it has its own needs for oil but two
is part of a welfare program for poor
people to heat their homes so is your is
your argument no the poor people should
freeze that way we won't the sun monster
won't be angry and we can appease the
great sun god and then he won't destroy
the world in 18 months or 12 years or
whatever they keep changing the number
no i don't think that
i am more interested in helping the poor
people heat their homes in the winter
helping
widows and orphans stay warm in the
winter
than i am in protecting a rock
or or the delta smelt or even the polar
bears who are doing just fine by the way
that's the first part that's so
ridiculous
the second part
that is so ridiculous is that he's he's
already by the end the dinosaur is
already taking it beyond climate change
beyond this one issue of he goes this is
an opportunity
this pandemic it's an opportunity for a
would you say a great reset i don't know
for a way to transform the economy to
transform it's a great opportunity and
the third thing that is really important
about this
is that it's a video of a dinosaur
lecturing world leaders
the not a scientist
not uh not an expert
a cartoon dinosaur
because
these are not serious people this is not
a serious
issue
this is a power grab based on
fear-mongering
and
bread and circuses and fantasy
the environmentalists
who are pushing for this
imminent destruction of the world or
pushing for massive global action the
upending of societies to stop the end of
the world they are not serious people
environmental activists from the group
extinction rebellion
have just had a big protest
and the way they protested fossil fuels
and pollution in the atmosphere
is to set up a prop boat
and set it on fire
and then fill the air with a bunch of
pollutants and smoke
and that's going to protest
filling the air with a bunch of
pollutants and
smoke is it
i don't
know that would be that would be
self-undermining i think
that would be like uh animal rights
activists
protesting the
harm done to animals by killing a bunch
of animals
which is literally what they do by the
way that's what peta does peta kills
animals so they actually it's a good
example they actually should
should look into that there as well
these are not
serious people this is not a serious
movement
it's not even opposed to the
ruling class i just read a headline
that greta thunderberg who is the most
prominent
the left really exploited her when she
was a kid now that she's
i think she's 18 now or 19. now that
she's no longer a kid they talk about
her less they're going to find some
other kid to exploit but
i read some headline that said greta
gutenberg is going to be appearing at
and protesting the climate summit
i mean she's not protesting the climate
summit
what do you mean protesting she's
invited
all the world leaders are they're all on
the same team
the activists and the politicians and
the media
and every powerful institution in the
whole wide world and corporate america
and big tech and the universities
they're all
they're all in agreement
there's no protest
it's it's theater it's kabuki theater
but there's what are they who are they
protesting
they're all all of those powerful groups
are protesting you all the people with
the power are protesting you who want to
keep your way of life and your liberties
and your system of government
and who have observed that all of the
kooky environmentalist claims of
armageddon that they've been pushing
since at least the 1970s and actually
much longer before that haven't come
true it was all a bunch
of bunk
people are recognizing that
you know even some leftists are
recognizing that there was a host on
msnbc
who called out her leftist guest from
the democratic party
and said hey
all you guys seem to be running on is
orange man bad all you're doing is
you're running against
trump
trump's not even in office anymore
trump is a looming threat but he's not
empowered democrats are and right now
democrats have not gotten anything done
on infrastructure voting rights gun
reform and police reform how do you get
voters energized in virginia for
democratic ideals not just against trump
so he the guy doesn't have a good answer
on any of these things and it's not
really important what he says he ends up
going he says well you know democrats
did this one thing or they sometimes do
this but you know yeah we gotta trump's
really bad trump's really bad but you
know the democrats are in trouble when
msnbc is is worried about it
right and and but you can just see it on
every issue joe biden's numbers have
tanked
joe biden who won virginia by 10 points
is now underwater there by 10 points
joe biden is underwater on every single
issue he used to be
above water on
on covid that was the one issue that
people approved of him on
he's now losing even on that issue
his approval rating is in the 30s
so i don't think the msnbc host is
necessarily calling out the strategy
because she's worried about fairness or
justice but at the very least she's
worried about her own party and she's
saying guys this is not a winning
strategy you got you got deep blue
virginia very possibly might give the
election to a republican
because of how much you guys are
screwing up
trump is the villain he's the scapegoat
he every problem in the world comes from
trump
but trump is not as relevant right now
as he was a few years ago maybe he'll
run for office again maybe he won't so
at the moment he's just not
particularly relevant so now they've got
to try to make a new
villain and the new villain they've
selected is ron desantis
msnbc also pushing this one of the more
eccentric hosts there joy read going on
a bizarre tirade against the governor of
florida
on sunday the florida republican
announced plans to offer unvaccinated
cops five thousand dollar bonuses to
relocate to florida and join police
forces there rolling out this perverse
dystopian tourism ad to the coveted blue
line
are you big on ordering people to comply
but you hate complying with health
mandates yourself
do you dream of arresting people's
ability to breathe while you arrest them
well pack up your potentially infectious
self your badge and your gun and come on
down to florida take this taxpayer bonus
money and enjoy constant interaction
with vulnerable senior citizens you can
breathe on
every breakthrough case in icu admission
is the virus of freedom spreading and
don't forget the sunscreen
is she okay
does someone need to check on joy
reid what joy reid has observed is this
policy that that rhonda santa says he's
saying if you get fired you're a cop
you're being fired because you won't
take the fouchyache because you're a
healthy person and you don't really need
it and your risk from dying of the virus
is very very low
and that we're told that the vaccine is
so super duper effective that it
protects you
regardless of how every anyone else
behaves it protects you from
hospitalization and death
so
look if you lose your job for that come
on down to florida we got a job for you
no
no he's it's evil you're going to kill
grandma you're going to breathe on
grandma don't worry grandma got the
vaccine it's fine you just told me that
the vaccine is fine and it protects you
no you it's an easy
and all they've got all they've got is
fear-mongering and insinuation and snark
she never makes any argument
right she never cites any scientific
facts she never makes any argument from
justice or science or anything else the
fact is desantis was right about
everything from the beginning of the
pandemic
almost every single decision he made
maybe every single one was correct and
cuomo got it wrong and newsome got it
wrong and biden's gotten it wrong and
everyone's gotten it wrong except for
this guy okay and forget about desantis
for a second this is true broadly on the
right
the government that we had before joe
biden came in was working a lot better
than the government we have now right
with joe biden and they can't make an
argument for it so all they've got is
their snark and their insinuation
and they're fearmongering
and
very little
else people are aware of that
their power is cracking a little bit in
the media in all of those institutions
then that's been building for a long
time and so now they're going to double
down they are not going to give up power
without a fight
that's why we got to hold the line i'm
michael knowles this is the michael show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show
republicans subject attorney general
merrick garland to a rough day in the
senate joe biden heads to an
international climate summit and the
state department says people of no
gender can now get their passports
stamped x
yeah that's happening that's today on
the bench i'll give it a
listen you